La volta al món a peu, dia 273, ha sigut una bona nit, però a les 11 o així han vingut els militars.
De cop i volta veig que m'estan apuntant amb una llanterna des de fora.
Dic, bueno, són uns nens, no?, que estaran curiosos, i no, no, surto i veig uns tios amb unes matralles a la carretera, eh?, no s'han apropat.
I res, jo m'he aixecat tranquil·lament amb la llum, enfocant-me a mi mateix perquè veiessin que no s'ocuparí,
i m'he apropat, turist, turist, m'han dit, ah, ok, ok, me n'he d'anar, i jo he dit, no, no, tranquil, et pots quedar.
Per tant, doncs res, tot bé, tot bé, però clar, normal que si a campo o al costat de la frontera vulguin saber què passa aquí, no?
Bueno, seguim, passen camions de sac, també, avui, ara a aquesta hora, sense novetats en aquest sentit, tocarà menjar pols.
Treva momentània de camions, ja us dic, passen tots a la vegada, durant mitja hora o una hora, i després ja deixen de passar.
I mireu, eh?, mireu quin tram de riu més ample.
I el que sempre em flipa a mi, el que sempre estic mirant, és la carretera d'Afganistan a l'altra banda, és el que sempre em fixo.
Passen motos, cotxes molt pocs, però algun de tant en quant.
Hi ha algú als comentaris de YouTube que m'ha explicat que, bueno, la frontera entre Tajikistan i Afganistan és bastant artificial, feta pels britànics,
perquè en realitat hi ha molta gent de la part afgana, d'aquesta part del nord, que són tajiks, ètnicament o nacionalment, com li vulguis dir, són tajiks.
Bé, una persona que ha oït els comentaris. Jo no puc investigar, no tinc internet.
Però m'ho crec, perquè no fa gaire, és a dir, ara fa aquest any, aquests mesos últims, sé que els talibans han estat tenint les seves trifulques
amb alguns grups insurgents just aquí, en aquesta banda d'Afganistan. Per tant, no ho sé, podria ser.
A les 9h, veig que aquí hi ha un restaurant.
Normalment, en aquest moment, hi ha un restaurant que es diu Al-Fahm.
I llavors, a les 8h, veig que hi ha un restaurant que es diu Al-Fahm.
De tot això, hi ha un restaurant que es diu Al-Fahm.
i això no tenen res, només tenen l'arròs, diu que està obert, si em donen alguna cosa, està bé.
Quants dies feia que no menjava carn, més enllà dels quatre trossos que posen al plof?
Mira, mira, m'han dit kebab, jo no sé si això és kebab, però anem a provar-ho abans de dir res.
Diria que és xai, és un gust bastant fort, està bo, és un gust bastant fort, eh? Sí, sí.
Potser massa pel meu gust de fort, però bé, bé, també en tinc pa i te, te negre.
Molt bé, tu, a les 9 del matí, però ja fomo, ja fomo a la Pamir perquè mai saps quan et trobaràs al restaurant.
Segueixen els camions, segueix la camioneta.
La carretera a trams molt polsagosa i mireu que m'he dignat a treure avui, avui sí, la mascareta.
Bueno, de normal no me la posaria ara, el que faria serà, just quan més o menys passa aquell camió pel costat,
doncs llavors sí me la poso i els 20-30 segons després és quan està la pols aixecada i quan tal.
He vist gent que als Himalaias es posa això no pels trekkings sinó per caminar per casa,
per carreteres i camins del Nepal on també hi ha molta pols,
i diuen que ho fan perquè, per avistar-se infeccions respiratòries,
perquè si tragues molta pols es pot pillar el gutxum o els pulmons, no sé.
Mira, mira, mira, mira.
Brutal, Teo, brutal.
És el pitjor d'aquest país, eh?
Realment brutal.
Bueno, mira, aquestes parets, aquesta vall avui de moment és molt molt molt estreta amb unes parets verticals brutals,
això és bo perquè tinc ombra.
Segueixo.
Doncs he pagat aquest restaurant que, mireu, està super bé, està super bé.
Mira, quina pantalla plana i tot.
No tenia molta gana per aquest matí, llavors he menjat només una amanida.
Veig bastant moviment, eh? Ja han vingut uns turistes occidentals,
ara aquí estaven asseguts també uns americans que estaven fent un tour,
i m'han donat aquesta aigua.
I bueno, res, són les 12 i mitja.
Encara em quedaré aquí 10 minuts més.
I després continuo.
Mira, molt interessant, un mapa que no havia trobat encara.
Un mapa d'aquesta regió de Tadjikistan, que no és tot el país, tot el país és això, d'acord?
I aquí tenim aquesta part.
Ara mateix estem per aquí, d'acord?
I jo he vingut caminant des d'aquí.
Aquí vaig fer el pas aquest, tal, tal, tal, el 3200 i pico.
He caminat fins aquí.
I ara la idea que tenia jo inicial,
la que tenia plantejada això, jo, era anar per aquí i arribar aquí.
Aquesta seria l'última ciutat gran, gran, entre cometes, eh?
Llavors, si no m'equivoco, perquè aquest mapa és una mica tal,
la primer highway seguiria per aquí, d'acord?
Llavors jo, en comptes d'anar per aquí i fer així,
la faria així, que és un tram que seria només senderisme.
O sigui, només senderisme, vull dir que aquí no passen camions, d'acord?
Feria una part de natura.
I aquí seria un tram que no hi ha absolutament res, fins a...
Murgap, que està aquí, això és Murgap?
Ostres, costa, costa de dir, eh?
O potser és això.
Potser és això, Murgap.
O és aquí. No sé, és complicat, eh?
Però bueno, per aquí i després ja crec que aquí,
Culma, sí, això és la frontera amb la Xina.
Culma, pas.
Hi ha una segona opció que fan els ciclistes,
els ciclistes italians aquells que vam veure,
fa una cosa que és bastant loca, és possible,
però si en comptes d'anar per aquí i fer això, d'acord?
Aquí es desvien,
i hi ha entre aquesta vall que té un nom bastant famós,
però no recordo ara mateix,
i aquí hi ha uns quants pobles, ok,
però aquí deixa d'haver-hi pobles ja,
i pum, pum, pum, crec que acabes aquí dalt, sí.
Acabes aquí dalt, o fas per aquí i acabes aquí dalt,
i després has de baixar per la highway fins aquí,
fins a Murgap, el que havíem dit.
Bueno.
No hi ha gaire diferència de distància de quilòmetres.
Encara que sembli que aquesta es desvia molt,
no hi ha gaire diferència de quilòmetres.
Aquesta és més curta, eh?
Però aquesta sí que és veritat que passa per un tram
que és molt llarg on hi ha molt pocs serveis.
Aquesta també té algun tram d'així, eh?
I aquesta passa per molt més trams off road,
on no hi ha tanta carretera i és una mica més lent l'avançament.
La veritat és que aquesta ruta no l'havia conegut
fins ara fa pocs dies,
que els italians han dit que anirien per aquí,
l'he investigat i ostres, ara estic una mica empipat.
Una mica empipat perquè quan a mi se'm presenta una decisió
que em trastoca els plans,
jo que soc una mica rígid potser,
dic ostres, ara he de prendre una decisió,
ara he de possiblement canviar els meus plans
perquè potser aquesta nova ruta és més maca,
perquè ja he dit que és molt maca,
doncs ara em toca una mica el d'això.
I si faig la ruta que tenia originalment pensada
estaré tota l'estona pensant
guai, si hagués anat per l'altra seria més guapo.
Però si faig per l'altra estaré pensant
guai, és que...
i si per l'altra anés més ràpid,
empiaré a l'hivern i no sé què, no sé quan.
No sé, no sé.
Probablement acabi de fer la ruta original,
però m'agrada expressar-vos el que estic pensant des d'ahir
perquè hi penso, hi penso en aquesta decisió.
Una i mitja més o menys
i fa una calor brutal.
Sé que ho dic cada dia
i és com que en repeteixo,
però és que el més important del meu dia
és la calor que fa.
Estic 8-9 hores caminant cada dia, no?
Llavors, és que és el més important dels meus dies
la calor que fa i el...
i això, això és el que condiciona més el meu dia, no?
El que em fa sentir, doncs, que dic
guai, és que és dommage.
Avui he campat.
O sigui, aquesta passada nit he campat als 1.600
i avui arribaré fins als 2.000
i ja mantindré la cota 2.000
fins als propers 3 dies, en principi.
I tu diries, bueno, 2.000 hauria de fer menys fred, no?
I menys calor.
No, sembla que no, eh?
Per la nit sí que és veritat que em tapo
amb el sac i estic bé,
però ara als migdia és...
és molt bèstia.
L'amplitud tèrmica...
Ja ho vaig dir, eh?
Això ja fa uns dies, però...
és molt, molt gran.
Bueno...
Sembla que va baixant.
És a dir, jo miro la previsió
i cada dia sembla que baixa un grau, no?
Això és positiu? A la vegada negatiu,
perquè quan arribi a la part més propera a la Xina, doncs...
m'interessa que no faci fred.
Però bueno, ja m'ho esperava
que a mesura que anem apropant-nos al setembre, doncs,
vagi fent menys calor, no?
30 d'agost, avui.
Avui fa 9 mesos
que vaig sortir del Passat Catalunya.
Ens apropem perillosament a l'any
de la volta amb una peu, eh?
Però no, no, encara queda.
Bueno...
Un tràiler...
Toca posar-se la...
la mascareta, eh?
Com si no n'hi hagués prou.
Una mascareta.
Què passa?
D'acord.
Deixem-nos marxar.
No fa', de seguida ho veurem.
Suposo que...
...que no ho sabrem.
Així és.
Vull veure com n'hi hagi下去 el sol.
Ha costat.
Són les 5 i deu,
però ja s'ha anat el sol, per fi.
Fu!
Estic en un tram del riu,
que és aquí, a un poble.
Mireu.
Sembla un embassament,
de lo tranquil·la que està l'aigua.
Molt bé, tu.
Ha sigut una atorramenta bestial
avui.
Em tocava el cos,
però em tocava el cos i
és que estava bullint.
Bullint, bullint. Com veieu,
un cotxe s'ha parat i m'ha donat
uns tomàquets. Hello!
I un pa.
Hello!
Que aquest és l'últim poble
que passo avui.
Ah, mira, aquí hi ha un màrquet.
Volia parar al màrquet.
Bueno, com podeu veure,
alguna dona sense vel.
Avui n'he vist quatre o cinc.
Sí, sí. Jo crec que
si en veiem una altra.
És una zona diferent del país que té
altres maneres de fer.
Però ara feia bastant de temps
que no veia dones sense vel.
Molt bé, molt interessant.
Doncs sí, això, vaig a comprar
alguna cosa. L'última compra del dia.
Doncs he fet la compra
i m'he assegut
per mirar les meves opcions
de campada. Ara que queda una hora i mitja perquè se'n vagi el sol.
I al següent
poble he vist que hi ha un homestay
que és com aquí li diuen a les guesthouse.
Que, bueno, dorms a casa d'algú.
I, bueno, no sé
quant val, no sé res, però hi ha un review que diu
és un dels millors jocs que m'he quedat
a Tajikistan. Hi ha dutxa calenta,
bany i no sé què.
Doncs, on dia?
Avui no ho tenia previst.
Tampoc ho necessito perquè
o sigui,
normalment aquests jocs et donen sopar,
et donen esmorzar i
avui he menjat bastant, però bueno,
el que sí que necessito és una dutxa.
Això a mi molt de gust.
A veure, ostres, el camió, tu.
Bueno,
l'únic problema és que està a 10 km
i són les 5 i 25,
per tant,
són unes dues hores de caminar,
dues hores i escaig, per tant, arribaria
a passar de la posta de sol,
però bueno, no passa res
per caminar una mica a les fosques.
Ostres, imagina't que arribo
i ja està ple.
No crec. Avui és diumenge, no?
No ho sé, no ho sé.
Creuem els dits.
L'ha patir la gió.
Així que gràcies,
per això en tornem a fer aquestkok,
a més al que no smash.
single
triple
directe
d'oberture
Fua! Guapíssim! Aquest últim tram, eh? M'ha encantat.
Em sobra amb la posta de sol, els colors... Genial, genial.
I he arribat. He arribat. En teoria és aquí.
Bé, ara miraré exactament on és. Són les 19h14 o 20h o alguna cosa així.
Uf! 46 km. Déu-n'hi-do. Vinga, va. A veure si tinc sort. Sisplau.
Sí. Sí, sí, sí, oi tant, oi tant. I lavabo i dutxa.
Oh! Ja m'he dutxat. Ha sigut gloriós. Ha sigut gloriós.
Amb xampús que hi fan servir per la casa. Vull dir que a sobre m'he rentat bé.
Bé, bé, bé. He sopat. He sopat una gran amanida. Molt bé. Una petita sopa.
I què més? I aquestes verdures plenes de carn. Més del que necessitava, però bé. Bé, bé, bé.
Te. Sempre et donen te per l'àpat. Cosa que a mi, amb aquestes calors, no em cal.
Però bueno, ara no fa calor. Ara s'està bé.
El jits. Com podeu veure. La coberta. És una manta. Ai, no manta. Una catifa.
Però després veig que té altres... altres mantes. Bueno, sempre tinc el sac si no m'és còmode.
Avui 46 o 47 km. I 3 refrescos. 32 euros gastats. 12 més 20 d'això, 20. 20 amb sopars, molts anys de feina.
I tres refrescos. 32 euros gastats. 12 més 20 d'això, 20. 20 amb sopars, molts anys de feina.
20 amb sopars, molts anys de feina. I tres refrescos. 32 euros gastats. 12 més 20 de això, 20. 20 amb sopars, molts anys de feina.
va, bé
bé, està bé
sí, sí, i he parlat amb
amb la nena que parlava
anglès d'aquí
d'algú més, potser d'algú més, posa-li
dues persones, ah sí, sí
no, he parlat amb més gent, posa-li quatre
i la nena aquesta
parla una mica anglès
parla rus, i li pregunto
parles tagíc? i diu sí, i parles
algun idioma més? 12 anys tindria
i diu
ah, pamir
és que
avui he preguntat a diverses persones si parlaven
algun idioma més, a part del
tagíc, i ningú m'ha acabat de respondre
perquè suposo que no m'entenien
però aquesta nena diu que parla pamir, ho he buscat
al pamir hi ha diverses llengües, per tant
no ens queda molt clar exactament
què parla, i després
li he preguntat, bueno, com es diu gràcies
en la teva llengua
i em diu caló
o alguna cosa així, i després he buscat i
no sé
en cap d'aquestes llengües
em surt aquesta paraula, no sé
investigaré més, però a mi sempre
m'agrada trobar les paraules
en la llengua local, especialment si és una llengua
que no és la llengua estatal, perquè llavors
jo crec que la gent se li explota el cap perquè no
no veig que ningú aprengui aquestes paraules, m'agrada fer-ho
però bueno, no sé si ho aconseguiré
tenint en compte això, que hi ha diverses llengües
vale, què més
ja està, dormiré
el millor possible
i demà continuem, queden 80
quilòmetres, i per tant, dos
dies, fins a l'última
ciutat principal
abans d'encarar
abans d'encarar el
Pamir autèntic i salvatge
Bona nit